So remember that set announcement servelet that you created
earlier? Now you're going to set up cron job
to run it regularly, say every minute, every ten
minutes, whatever, to update the announcement. So to set up
your cron job, you're going to need to create
a cron.xml file and configure it to run /cron/set_announcement
because that's the path that we set up for
our set, set announcement function. And then specify the schedule,
let's say once per minute. The development server on
localhost doesn't run cron jobs, so when you're ready, go
ahead and deploy your app to appspot. Then add one
or more conferences that have between zero and five seats
available. And the easiest way to do that is
just to create a new conference with max attendees less
than five. And then use the cron viewer in the
Admin Console to make sure that your cron job's running.
And then of course go ahead and get the latest
announcement to check that the latest announcement did get updated. And
you can do this either, you can use either the mem-cache
viewer or the API's console to get the latest announcement. So
now your cron job is humming along, it'll keep going
by itself. That means it's going to run a query to look
for conferences every minute, or however often you scheduled it to
run. It's helpful for learning purposes to see the cron job
running frequently, but it's not a good practice to leave cron
jobs running more frequently than you really need them. This cron job
does a fairly simple query, and then puts a value in mem
cache, for which there's no daily quota. But if your cron job
did something that intensively hit the data store it could easily use
up much more quota. So you need to think about what your
cron jobs do and how often they need to run. I've accidentally
used up my entire daily quota running a cron job that searched
all the conferences and saved results in the data store, so
I learned my lesson the hard way. So go ahead and
change the frequency to once an hour and when you've done
that come over here and check this box. Alternatively, you could disable
the cron job completely by uploading an empty cron job config,
but remember if you just delete the cron config file completely
then the one that's already up on app spot stays running.
So one more quick quiz. How do you schedule your cron job
to run once every two hours? Go ahead and enter
that value in here. And that's it for cron jobs.